Gale had stories for Stephen Colbert  about growing up in Turkey last night on  The Late Show her father was an  electronic engineer for the US  government but Colbert spidey-senses  told him he thought her dad was really a  spy  we had a room that we were not allowed  to go into he had he was a ham operator  and that was his hobby my mom said he  was a ham operator so no Ice Station  zebra hello this is winter Fox calling  no Vicky's FlyLo no this is in the  basket the squirrel is in the basket  there would be times that he would be in  there going also talked about CBS this  morning's new note to self book which is  available now  yes I believe my parents I believe my  mom and whenever I tell that story  people go Gale come on be real I know I  did I was like I bet the dad's working  for the government in Turkey I did have  that spidey sense and you guys watch the  news every night  Ya Allah double-oh-seven it's really  Gayle we gotta go